Bachelor Nations Sarah Herron and her
fiance Dylan Brown reveal their newborn
son has died
on Wednesday Sarah shared the
heartbreaking news on Instagram posting
several pics from her pregnancy along
with this image cradling their newborn
whom they named Oliver in the caption
Sarah writes that they welcomed Oliver
on January 28th at 24 weeks old 16 weeks
early there are no words for the
magnitude of loss and pain we're
experiencing it's beautiful and
simultaneously tragic
Sarah adds that Oliver who was conceived
by IVF defied so many odds and fought to
be here
and while their time together was short
Sarah says she remains grateful he has
taught us so much about the Integrity of
Life Love and Death Oliver filled our
home and hearts with so much love and
most importantly optimism
Sarah adds that their son's purpose was
bigger than they'll ever understand and
to them his legacy will always be larger
than life
Sarah and Dylan got engaged in 2021
after four years of dating I met him
because I recently just moved to
Colorado to run the organization that I
started called she lift and I was
looking for a photographer a director I
was referred to Dylan and I hired him
the two had been trying to get pregnant
for two years Dylan's Gonna Be pricking
Me in the stomach because I don't think
I have the guts to do it myself they
announced their pregnancy back in
September after being candid with fans
about their struggles with infertility
and documenting her IVF Journey on
Instagram just wanted to give a little
update
night one went really great but I would
be
dishonest with you
if I didn't tell you how painful it's
been so I'm very excited that this will
be the last one I'm doing for now
at the time Sarah shared these snaps
writing we can't keep a secret any
longer our Embryo transfer was a success
and I am pregnant with our baby boy and
during a q a shortly after that Sarah
noted that they have one boy and three
girl embryos remaining
of course fans first met Sarah on Sean
Lowe season of The Bachelor in 2013.
I live by myself and I have a dog but at
the end of the day like I'm looking for
someone to share my life with
she went on to appear on the first
season of Bachelor in Paradise in 2014
and returned to the beach for season
three in 2016. if this is not the time
to find love I don't know when is and
when E.T chatted with Sarah back in 2017
she knew she had met her happily ever
after I ended up going out to coffee
with them and fell in love and we've
been Inseparable since he wants to help
me get out and explore and learn more
because I'm trying to get more
adventurous and and so it's great we're
like Adventure buddies slash creators
and we both just want to like do good
and it's awesome to be around you know
positive
inspiration like that
foreign